in this last video we illustrate how to
use the techniques we have recently
learned in order to answer some
questions about the following classical
problem consider a gambler putting a bet
of $1 in a game that has a payoff of $1
if she wins we assume that this is a
fair game so that the probability of
winning $1 on each play of the game is
one-half and so the priority of losing
the bet is also one-half suppose that
she starts with I dollars and continues
to play the game until either she
reaches a goal of n dollars or she has
no money left whatever come first let us
consider a first question which is the
following what is the probability that
she ends up with having her goal of n
dollars now how to go about solving this
problem can we think of a Markov chain
representation for this problem but in
that case what would be good choices for
the definition of the state let us think
at any point in time the only relevant
information is the amount of money the
gambler as available how she got to that
amount in the past is irrelevant and if
this amount is neither 0 nor n then she
will play again and the next state will
be a number which will be increased or
decreased by one unit depending on
winning or losing the next bet so we can
represent the possible evolution of this
game with the following probability
transition graph so we have n plus 1
States this is the state where she loses
all the money this is the state where
she has AI amount of money before the
next betting and here this is the state
and where she reaches her goal and she
can lead in terms of the transition
probability assuming that you are at the
given time
in that state that means that you have
I'm money in your pocket and you play
the next bet with a perky 1/2 you will
gain or win and so your amount of money
is I plus 1 or you lose and your money
is I minus 1 and you keep repeating
until you reach either n or 0 and then
you stop so this is a Markov chain and
that state 0 and that state and are
absorbing states once you reach them
you stay there forever so what this
question is asking is the probability a
of I of starting from hi what is the
probability that you will end up in that
absorbing state and we have done this
calculation previously so let us repeat
the technique very briefly clearly here
if you start with $0 you will never
reach that so it's going to be 0 on the
other hand if you start with your
desired goal you don't play anymore so
your prodigy is 1 now of course what is
of interest is if I is strictly between
0 and n and now the question is how to
calculate that probability and we have
seen that the way to do that is to look
at the situation and say well let's
assume that you are in that state I and
what will happen next well with a pie
which is 0.5 you will move to that state
and now you are in that level with I
plus 1 amount of money and what is the
probability that given that you are here
you're gonna end up in n is going to be
AI plus 1 so it's 8 I plus 1 plus the
other alternative is that you are going
to lose money and end up in that state
and there the remaining probability to
reach the time and is AI minus 1 so you
have this kind of equation this is valid
for all I between 0 and n and
[Music]
this is a system of equation that you
can solve it's not very difficult to
solve actually you can look in a
textbook there will be some trick to do
that there are many many ways to do that
when I can spend our time explain going
that in details but essentially if you
solve that system you will see that the
answer will be that a of I is I over N
so if you start with I amount of money
the probability that you're going to
reach your goal and here is I over N so
here clearly if you're extremely greedy
and you had a very very very high goal
that means n is very very loud so large
that compared to your initial amount I
and can be considered to be infinity
then the probability that you can reach
your high goal will go to 0 where n get
goes to infinity so again if you're
extremely greedy
nobody are much your fixed amount of
initial money is the probability that
you will stop the game reaching your
goal is going to be increasingly small
and since the author state is 1 minus
this one the priority that you're going
to get ruined is going to be closer to 1
all right so we have that answer here
what about the next question next
question is the following what would be
the expected wealth at the end again
this is a Markov chain where there are
two absorbing States all the others are
transient you are guaranteed with
priority one that you will reach either
0 or n so it's a valid question to know
once you reach either 0 or n what is the
expected wealth at the end well it's
going to be if you arrive here it's
going to be 0 and if you arrive here
it's gonna be n so the expected value of
that wealth will be 0 times the priority
of running in that plus n times the
gravity of the game there so it's going
to be that expression 0 times 1 minus a
of I plus n times a of I and here what
we then
it is n times I over N which is I which
is quite interesting this is exactly how
you started
so in some sense in expectation there is
no free lunch here the next question is
how long does a gambler expect to stay
in the game we know that eventually you
will either reach zero or n with
property one the question is how long is
it going to take and again we have seen
in a previous video that this is
essentially calculating the expectation
to absorption and we know how to do that
so let's recap what we had said if you
define mu of I to be the expected number
of plays starting from I what do you
have well for I equals zero
or I equals n either way if you start
from here or you start from here the
expected number of play is zero right
because you're done and otherwise you
use the same kind of derivation that we
had if you start at I between 1 and n
then you will see that mu of I after one
transition plus 1 you will either be in
state I plus 1 and in that case this
expectation will be mu I plus 1 or you
will be in state I minus 1 and that case
the expectation is mu I minus 1 so this
is an equation that you have which is
almost the same as this one except that
you have a plus 1 in it and as we had
discussed before in general this is the
kind of formula that you have now you
can solve the system I will let you do
that there are many ways to do this but
the solution that you're going to have
is that mu I will be equals to I times n
minus 1 this is the result
family what would be the case if you
didn't have a fair game for example and
fair to the gambler or unfair to the
casino so what we mean here is that the
probability P is different from 0.5 so
here instead of 0.5 you have P
everywhere and here of course you have 1
minus P everywhere on this side so you
have a priority P of winning and
priority 1 minus P of losing each bet so
you might ask the same question well for
the probability of AI you still have
zero here you still have 1 here the
formula that you would write here
instead of writing it this way it would
be you start from here with a very P you
might appear and with a priority 1 minus
P you end up there
and the expression that you get for a of
AI if you define R to be 1 minus P over
P you will see that a of I is going to
be 1 minus R at the power I over 1 minus
R at the power n and what would be the
expected amount of time she will play
instead of that equation if you solve it
you would have mu of I equals R plus 1
divided by R minus 1 times I minus n
times 1 minus R I divided by 1 minus R
at the power n
because you would have here again P and
1 minus P here and you can see that when
P is strictly less than 1/2 in other
words it's even worse for this gambler
then a of I which is the priority of
getting to this favorable state will
also go to 0 when n goes to infinity and
in the case where P is strictly greater
than alpha that means that she has some
favored odd on her favor then in that
case this number are at the power n will
go to 0 and 1 minus R of I will
represent the probability that she would
become infinitely rich in other words a
being very greedy and going to infinity
this will go to 0 and 1 minus R the
power R is the priority that she would
get infinitely rich